ていた
[音楽]
この中で1から
そんなの常識でしょとか
こんな常識も知らないのとか言われたことある人はーいっ
お仲間いる
そもそも
その人の言ってる常識って
正しいの
時にはその常識歩1歩おっしゃっても良くないですかねぇ
僕は大学の時常識を超え行くことを知って
人生の選択肢が無限に広がったんです
今から8分で僕が25年かけて悟った常識の声方とメリット
みんなの人生が素敵に広がっていくよ
シェアさせてください
[拍手]
10代の頃
常識って大人が守っていくものだと思ってた
常識とはグーグル先生によると
一般人が共通に持つ普通の知識あっ白分別
これ
ずれています
世界15年
延べに150カ国
さすらい続け悟ったこと
世界は
宗教が強く
宗教が異なれば常識も異なるんです
75年前の常識で言えば人殺しすら
戦時中はたらしく今は正しくないつまり常識とは
国や時代で異なり
絶対的なものでもなく
常に
変化していくものなんです
大学のとき
僕の
フランス親友でフランス育ちの奴が
いきなり
こっちですね
俺
第5件に目指す
ファースヨファ
だってそうじゃないですか大学卒業してマネー
道端でゲイしてお金をもらう意味わかんないですよ
就職するのが常識ショッ
でもねぇ
バイトしながら
数週間考えて
気づけたんです
他人に米迷惑をかけず
お金をもらえるなら
それはバイトも
大道芸人も
すべて
花お仕事
僕は就職しか考えてなかったんですけど
常識を超えた発想で人生
いろんな選択肢があるんだなあって
気づけた出来事でした
大学を卒業した後
常識を超え行く
発想の仕事ひらめいたんす
世界をさすらうプロギャンブラー
わくわくするしよう
でもね僕
ギャンブルしてなかったんですん
だから
世間の常識だけじゃなく僕の常識からも声行くことだったんです
常識ないに生きてれば
平穏な人生なのに常識を超えたことだけどどうしても是非してみたい
それは
自分の内からあふれだす
本心なんです大会で扱って
僕は生まれて初めてなんです
本気になれるって感じたのがいい
奈良
常識を超えてでもトライしなきゃと
丸1年半
毎日13時間
誰よりもギャンブルの勉強そして努力しまくって
分かった答え
カジノ業界で
f 休ま由瓶クマー
賢ければ稼げるよ
その常識は
昔の常識だったんですつまり勝てないってこと
北丸1年半
すべての時間すべてのお金全ての思いを
そこにかけてた
勝てないって分かった昔の常識ってわかったときは
もうショックデー
ちー狂いそうになって
本当にでキーくる一歩手前までいっちゃったんです
以下月号
カジノ業界の常識で
勝てないって言われてる火事のあったなーって思い出したんです
カジノの常識で勝てる丸と言われているところが罰だったの分かったなら
罰と言われているところが
丸な可能性あるんじゃないのってひらめきが降りてきたんです
ひらめきとあ
あなたの脳があなたのために考えるあなただけへのメッセージ
とても大事に宝物のように扱って
僕はねすぐアメリカとんだ
そして
ついに
カジノから追い出されたす
それはプロと認められた証
もし僕が常識にこだわりすぎてて従いすぎてたら
ゲームオーバー
立っています
ここで
常識を超えるときのコツをシェアさせてください
常識を超えるとき
壁があるありますそれを僕は見口バリアー言っています
みゅーじバリアとは何かしたいって言い出したとき身内からの反対の声
わっ
今何言いました
それ常識で無理無理やめときなさい
何かしたいことが見えたとき
身内バリアーを説得できるかっていう勝負になります
プロギャンブラーとはその勝ち方として全ての判断を
他人説明できるレベルで言語化する
身内を説得できなければその後やってくる大きな壁に対し自分自身を
説得できなくなりますか
まぁこんな偉そうな事ちょっと言いましたけど僕常識から見たらただのアゴ数
15件プロギャンブラーというアフォを続けてきて
最近
悟ったことがあります
アホも続ければ
立派な方になる
ナースやつ
まとめさせてください
せっかく人生恋愛仕事などにおいて
素敵な出会いや素敵なひらめきが降りてきたのに
常識的に反対されそう
諦めないでほしいんです
もし今まであきらめていることあったら
今から渡来して素敵な人生通りに言ってほしいんです
だって
常識なんかに縛られず自分のしたいことするのが
自分の人生勝ち方ですから
最後に
常識を超える時の10問を僕の後に復唱してもらってもいいですか
ジョジョ好き怖いっ
ティファン城町
全然常識の凝りまくってる
マット今までね自分が常識的に声の大きさってこれくらいかなあっていうの歩1歩を
愛して今大声で一緒に常識超えましょう石か常識ぽいバーイ
あだ
[拍手]